welcome to podcast ville the Church of
what's happening now is brought to you
by blue I put blue open is deleting milk
it delivery service in the United States
and while many people know what we do
many don't know about that types of
meals you eat when you cook with blue
apron you're not just having burgers for
dinner you're making short rib burgers
with a hoppy cheddar sauce and on a
pretzel bun you're preparing to see it
steaks with thyme pan pan sauce with
mashed potatoes green beans and crispy
shallots all in under 45 minutes and
without a trip to the grocery store you
know why because blue apron is the
number one fresh ingredients and recipe
delivery service in the country now let
me drop it on you this way I know
Thanksgivings coming you're sitting
there you start your resolutions blue
apron is gonna take you my church family
to their first and we're gonna invite
you with treatment it's a $30 value what
you're gonna do is go to blue apron calm
slash Joey Jo ey check out this week's
menu and get $30 off with free shipping
at blue apron calm slash Joey blue apron
a better way to cook all right number
two while we're talking about cooking
what goes in must come out and that's
why the [ __ ] bidet is back especially
now during Thanksgiving when all these
[ __ ] savages come over your house to
express gratitude and recollect on what
you're truly grateful for it's also time
when all these people come over to eat
your food they your [ __ ] pumpkin pie
and then they blow your bathroom up with
their post-meal shits this year make
sure when your family takes that dump of
death in y'all's they leave with a clean
[ __ ] get a touchy birthday for $69
with a risk-free 60 day trial don't have
your [ __ ] fat grandma walking around
with that gravy ass because she was too
[ __ ] flimsy with the toilet paper to
wipe go to hell old [ __ ] table right
now and use code Church
si-hu are CH for 10% off your order -
she calm hello - she calm a better way
to treat you [ __ ]
and while we're at it listen freaky
[ __ ] Black Friday is coming you want
to be a part of it for months years
everybody hates me Joey
what should you do - geek Fujii [ __ ]
and if I gotta pick one it's the
Saporito I got the psycho the Seco sei
ko and I got the Saporito and I got the
[ __ ] devil elemental but my favorite
is the Saporito it's lightweight
I'm a fat [ __ ] - tongue on my neck
all you want
you can't break my posture the [ __ ]
thing won't break go to Fuji Sports calm
right now press in church I get 10% off
your order who's better than uncle Joey
kick this [ __ ] the mealy [ __ ] yeah
buenos dias [ __ ] uncle Joey here
ready to rock it's a whole new week
you're giving it three days then
Thursday you're gonna eat turkey you get
to see your family and it's a great
[ __ ] time of the year because you
know what you think about last year what
were you doing last you know it was a
[ __ ] prison cafeteria that [ __ ]
petrified turkey with her fake dark meat
I gave him half off at Danny's and [ __ ]
that's the worst I went to Denny's one
time for Thanksgiving the family was mad
at me and [ __ ] now hey you don't [ __ ] it
then I'll go to Danny's by myself listen
man that Boston Market the night before
see they [ __ ] it up but well I was
single [ __ ] I was living out there like
a nomad couple Thanksgivings you got a
loaf of Wonder Bread you get some
[ __ ] turkey sliced thin from [ __ ]
Boston Market some gravy something yeah
some stuffing I don't like any type of
stuff I like prison stuff the stovetop
yeah stovetop baby both top you'd open
up with some sausage forget about it
Stefan yeah it's sent a cardboard box
that's my mom in it stuffing I love I
love so talk she added stuff to it but
yeah you got a dope it up that's what
I'm saying yes can I add the celery and
this time in kid juice you know it's
funny before we were talking about this
show I've been watching on Netflix call
Jota Jota been boletos [ __ ] Pablo
Escobar I'm not recommending it to
nobody you know why because it's
completely in [ __ ] Spanish and I
follow the subtitles none even know what
the [ __ ] they saying like speaks bad but
it's a very interesting show and Lee you
know you know uh George Perez is on the
show great [ __ ] comic on his way
[ __ ] up to take over
he's like the capo regime - [ __ ]
Philippe right now he's like it's funny
that it's crazy how like you thought of
me when you told me that you were mad at
me for not watching it what's that right
when I walked in you're like are you
watching this for my show it's it's
superb especially if you've been locked
up because number one you see how lucky
we are oh yeah that's a prison in
Colombia
I don't [ __ ] around they were actually
in that prison you slipped there the
paramilitary they get you first small
free
they got buckets acid in that but in the
bathroom they chop you up and they put
you in the ass and they drink yeah
body's here with this capital pretty ah
all the time I heard of this one of the
worst prisons in Colombia I could take I
just happen to watch that show a few
weeks ago it was on it was on Netflix
then we watched the first dirt war one
or two episodes and it was amazing when
he went from the prison and the city
where they liked him to the prison to
the prisoner of the enemy and how it was
a completely different completely
[ __ ] different and it was like nice
hair and he's scared the first days and
the characters that they've put this
they put one of the guys can go valet
he's like one of the leaders what's del
Valle
that they were the cartel that was the
enemies to the malindo to the via no
okay yeah they all turned on Medellin
but they all became part of Cali cartel
okay and then the [ __ ] whatever you
know whether it's true or not I'm just
telling you what I saw
nothing in those days but they went on
their own and look to the valley because
they had they control the docks so you
could do it a [ __ ] they want
oh yeah I mean if it's coming in
touching it as if they were sending it
out yeah so if who knows coke went out
before Tom Perez's oh mine exactly you
followed me saw this guy was in there
and he's such a nasty [ __ ] dude that
you got a lovin mm-hmm he's totally
soprano with no class at all yeah with
no immigration or emigration no class
there's no rules in that world really
what big [ __ ] phenomenal characters
they're just they're awesome petrified
of extradition the whole war with Pablo
was about extradition that's it because
jail in Colombia
you know visitation they go to yourself
for three hours they don't even have
like a little in no no no no hookers
come in they got visiting boots but on
certain days you get and then after a
while they have conjugal visits and it's
an interesting show because it shows you
what's going on in the jungle and what's
going on in the prison what scared
our military what's going on with the
[ __ ] nah but it's funny like when I
tell talked to Lee how when I got locked
up I didn't know what the [ __ ] to expect
I had a friend that had been through the
system and I contacted him I didn't know
him directly and this is in the 80s to
the savvy will do with him yeah if you
get locked up in 80 when I got locked up
I got in trouble it was 30 years ago on
unsettled sadly I was still the street
now I didn't turn myself in for the 21st
I committed the crime on the 18th
yeah but they want to mold the man huh
the 18th was a Tuesday the NP was a
Tuesday where he was and I had Wednesday
Thursday and I finally came down the
hill Friday morning and I turned myself
and I did
in County and that was like nothing that
was not about getting my head together
thinking about things
Oh can't can't be nothing nothing
it is nothing at that time you talking
about you checked into the Holiday Inn
for a month Holiday Inn for the blonde
no you didn't my old cell cable TV
carpeting cigarettes you rolled your own
cigarettes old friends old friends no no
no I made a bunch of friends and their
new friends people I'd read about in the
paper like Aryans I'd read about in the
paper they were there they were all in
there
ha the first guy I met was the dude that
was snorting coke and got so paranoid he
thought he heard somebody kicking down
his door so he jumped off his balcony
and he broke both legs she wasn't
walking for the cell I saw a dude with
two broken cass-clay there was a I was
like oh [ __ ] I read about that [ __ ]
suit the best stories three months old
there was just it was like and then I
stayed there for four days think he's
doing evaluation if you had a job at the
time and go to school they put you this
is one ball the county jail was
completely different and when by
different it was like it was you wore
your own clothes oh I can't got you now
okay
breakfast was legit lunch was legit and
dinner was legit day if you got to the
top tier you didn't have to be a trustee
you could stay up till 2:00 okay and
watch TV then there were trustees I
could never be a trustee because I got
arrested for a violent crime yeah
so the worst I can go up to his level
red which was cable TV your own cell
[ __ ] gym all day yeah they're not
gonna give you responsibility no so I
got there it took me about seven days to
get the level rent and listen to me 30
years later the jail his name was Ron I
don't know what it was about this dude
we started talking and we headed off and
he goes listen anytime you need to leave
use the phone just let me know didn't
cost me a dime
oh wow remember Thanksgiving there was
the play called everybody who I knew and
so wisdom locked up I'm sorry I let you
down you know yeah and that's sad that I
sat in there from the 21st of December
November to like the 18th of December
bro
it was brutal that yeah you remembered
everybody's number and it came to life
in your head huh Oh like how I met I met
a dude in there that I had read about
that this is one of the weirdest things
he was in his car with his kid and his
wife and he was high on drugs and he
flipped a Jeep over and his kid died
boom I've got me wrong and when they
grabbed him they found that he was
looking for murder fell as he is in
Florida we kill for people with DUI Oh
like I just met these people in County
Jail that were [ __ ] nuts
I met this family called the Marley's
they they were white trash look at me
I love white people these people watch I
know what you mean duh good-hearted
white people trash what they did was
they started a long time landscaping
company
father and son okay
father and son landscaping company they
[ __ ] rocket they've run along but
Tamar please
the [ __ ] door nah the Sun hasn't a
wife she's pregnant they have kids the
whole thing one day they got a bright
idea to start selling coke along with
George they went from zero to sixty you
know yeah yeah yeah you've seen it
I say hey it went it's taglio Lee I've
seen people like you one day go Joey I'm
gonna start getting out once a week from
his Mexican do know he's giving it to me
for six hundred myself for sixteen Grimm
if you know anybody and next thing you
know eight we play it I'll see you with
a brand-new car yeah Jack my shirt
telling me a condo is Sherman Oaks I'm
like what and then a year later I see
you and you're really ripped like you're
ripping with [ __ ] dollar and now
you're really ripped like you got three
guys let you deliver the [ __ ] quarter
pounds to
a week like you're not that [ __ ] dude
no more you don't even talk to people on
the street you just the guy that meets a
Mexican guy once a week and it gives you
a bag with a pound of blow you take it
to your girlfriend's house not Paul this
wall is the woman you live with yeah I
got that girl like in Goodfellas that
cooks up that you pay for her apartment
let's go with a lying on your party as
you water yeah yeah you can weigh it
with the knife mom you don't even give a
[ __ ] she sucks your Pole okay you weigh
your coat you liver a coke rocky give a
thrill our bills for the rent she ain't
even know whether that [ __ ] hasn't
either no boy no girl with a spoon of it
and the refrigerator takes a sip out of
it once a day
it's [ __ ] hysterical and you know
what unless you and I can tell you this
and we giggle but I've seen it
no I feel I drop insulative and these
guys and next thing you know they went
from sowing grams the selling Cupid's
bow [ __ ] ups and bro they had longmont
controlled right so they started it this
is a average family rice as an average
[ __ ] American family what about
stress listen to me forget about your
stress repose yeah when you see your
money add up the look in your [ __ ]
suitcase on G your bed and there's
800,000 casts that you made the last
year yeah and you haven't spent a dime
we haven't said a word to Paula for 20
years yeah you're gonna go to jail you
deal with professional people you in you
get to a point that you have a circle
and that circle is solid George already
did time he ain't scared of doing time
now you know yeah I already did time all
right it's gonna do it 100,000 I'll do 3
you know what I mean you can move four
[ __ ] kilos a week no listen just a
little but just hear me out I'm hearing
you out no Sarah fine it doesn't matter
what you want leave your muzzle how you
freedom in there - I'm talking to you
about us this family so the families
fellas selling blow but I mean they they
got so greedy and there was so white and
so on experience that they started
selling ounces
but if you wanted to have him call the
house ah stupid but bro in the meantime
they bought four new trucks everybody
have motorcycles damn buddy yeah your
Lord
okay finally the [ __ ] thing up they
got raided I never forget reading about
this in the paper and it was like a
[ __ ] you know the end of the money
cars and trucks yeah flossing too hard
flossing too hard
plus I mean that they just showed they
show their money wisely you keep that
Volkswagen and if it gets that did you
give we got two hundred not the same
nothing yeah you keep the death on it
because nobody thinks you're a coke
dealer when you pull up with a dent in
your faucet right now do you understand
me
now you show up with a Maserati and your
wife gets out a new head doing a ring on
her finger
you're a dead man and just take a couple
weeks the math does not add up
yeah like in Goodfellas when when I got
shut up with the pink Cadillac and the
mink
yeah they throw a [ __ ] bomb we
don't wanna know about that [ __ ] that's
your stupid world but here's the funny
thing
this dude who we talked about talking
about this family that regard Berkeley
yes well no the DA got involved or all
these people were selling big numbers
when they wouldn't end up stay [ __ ]
cash and they found more cash and more
cash they found more cash so the DEA was
involved this is how [ __ ] up the
government is just so people think about
things that will then make you find that
a lot when you get locked up a straight
line especially you little federal place
for a few weeks you find that the
trickery of the government yeah so what
these guys did was and their
investigation guess what they found out
George what the father was [ __ ] the
daughter-in-law now where does a him 69
and Willis uh when how old was she
28 he was 50 and [ __ ] they were doing
that dad had this affair for two years
well she was probably making four
hundred thousand a year law is adorable
they were making money as a family they
were living like
even though haven't had four plus four
that's a good point George the point was
they started [ __ ] yeah so now no
offense were there said can we show you
something
and they showed the said the wife no
they showed the same oh it's like you're
my brother
no no no I'm your father and I'm [ __ ]
your wife when you're at work see so
it's my landscaping company you had ten
Mexicans you're white you got ten
Mexicans you're making tons of money out
there while you're out there mowing
lawns I'm [ __ ] your wife they're
[ __ ] my wife Wow he's got kids wash
they're at daycare she comes back from
yoga
you give a dick that's fifty
five-year-old dick so now the feds went
back in there and showed the pictures to
the son I said what do you want to do
John you want to snitch you want a
snitch so the son ratted flip Tom so I
lost him in County Jail I caught back up
with them at diagnostic it's hysterical
what happens like I still remember
vividly that story but I also remember
another [ __ ] story I saw a guy in
there that was nice to me in County and
I was nice to him Maibaum we never
talked like you know those people you
talk to yeah just had a respect okay so
I made bail
I make bail five days before Christmas I
get out I got a job I worked for a few
days I get fired I'm crack you know
they're looking at me nine years I start
shoplifting I make up my mind listen if
I'm gonna go [ __ ] prison must feel
with three hands don't effort so I go to
prison get out of your money or [ __ ]
anything
you gotta pound the coat yeah I'm only
dealing with people I know flipping it
exactly gonna sell to mold I know who
wouldn't turn it on me so now I went to
work that January 80th of 88 I knew
listen I might go to president I might
have might have a year yeah there's a
chance I was trying to get a hitman to
kill the victim
watch by the way people I did call Kent
Vela on November 18th and apologize to
him for kidnapping and 30 years ago that
day 10 he never called me back so I got
a dog I you know now that I've become a
comedian I've been getting hit up by
people I hate to sell coke and weed to
like back in the early nineties and
they're like damn dog you were always
funny when you sold this weed and coke
too and I was just like I can't [ __ ]
believe the world I used to be in like
it's a when you sell coke and weed your
customers are [ __ ] very sketchy and
weird like really well I was gonna ask
it is if you do just if you're just a
pot dealer or weed dealer it seems to be
like gonna be like the best job ever if
you got if you had it down in the people
you trust it
yeah that's a nice job like look look
Lee at the end of the day any real
[ __ ] drug he is gonna rob you
for $50 that you have to be very trust
who you're gonna go after be rather sell
weed then crack right yeah but coke is
way more people are coming way faster to
buy it from you at night so when you
sell out so if you saw ounce of weed
that shit's gonna be with that guy for a
week if you saw ounce of coke and this
fool is having a party he'll be there in
the morning
but Lee also he remembers a thousand
different situations okay Lisa I gets a
job at give me a chain darling a chain a
Red Robin can you get a job as a
bartender that you got 15 [ __ ] kids
from 21 to 24 and all they talk about is
going on doing drugs you're best friends
with this [ __ ] jamoke over here his
cousins are gonna cartel they got kilos
what are you laughing about
it's because of the cartel you make 850
an hour and you pulled down $50 a night
and tips and you got a girlfriend you're
trying to play Joey bananas and you got
a [ __ ] face count and you got a car
payment to Volkswagen and you got to pay
[ __ ] student loans you go to your
friend George Shinn you go George all
these people talk about cocaine and you
teach me anything about it
never done it before those are the
people that make the money guys like you
gonna take 14 grams throw three grams of
color on it
Georgia waiting up for you gives you 17
every package has a rock I'm at the end
of the week you're gonna be selling to
you're gonna see George twice a week
kinda like you make some money are you
scared are you ever scared no because
you sell it at the bar now do you solve
the customers are you one of those
[ __ ] you don't know nothing you have
it hidden somewhere that nobody could
find it the cameras aren't on you maybe
somebody drops it off at a certain time
and you distribute it you see what type
of night it is and George asks you if
Joey asks you of P - you so that's one
way of sitting at home do you bring it
home with you or do you leave it in that
spot you leave it in this spot but then
you're a professional aren't you
terrified all night I'm going home
thinking but that's a people no man
that's real five Paul is home right now
she knows what you do
you're both doing it because you want to
do it get away Paul I had a cousin who
did it so it ain't that bad lately yeah
yeah you selling or anything on it so
now every time you call Paul up my love
and go bring six packages over here
bring eight just in case all the shows
up gives you a packages you give my aunt
some money
once this hold you go back to George and
nobody knows nothing I know people have
done that for 20 years and now one time
done in trouble now not one time okay
cuz then I know people who are savages
who go to a bar to drink and they become
such great friends at the bartender that
whenever somebody comes to the bartender
think I came in a couple times he knows
them he's friends with Tommy he grew up
with him
that's Mikey's little brother that's how
happy sends you over that's the worst
way yeah but you're gonna move you're
gonna make $1,000 a night oh my god but
you're out there you're risking
everything now you're coming home you
bring them [ __ ] home with you they
start talking you take the other thing
out you start talking about the cartel
your buddy George you're gonna take over
the city there's different ways to do it
and there's people who would dumb [ __ ]
to this trader who are [ __ ]
professional
then there's people joints - there's
people legal oh you know what Joey's a
comedian I don't know any mess on the
weekend I don't miss on the podcast but
George gets this [ __ ] [ __ ] that makes
people's hair stand up in fact I had a
customer with bought some tiny house and
the heavy metal rug then the coat
hangers from George let me just ask Joey
and it comes to Joey one day and Joey
loves you he's not going to judge it you
notice they join you ready
if I get you an ounce of coke on the
street value it's 12 but I'll give it to
you for 750 the other two bring one by
every week and I'll say you don't want
me I will do that much come bring a bag
on a young 22 year old that's suck man
so like ever enable and now you bring
one to me every week and then you bring
one to six imaginary comedians that we
know do cocaine that'll be well off that
you doing them a favor because they
don't have to go into the street to look
for it mm-hmm oh you're not a cop pretty
soon you're getting half a kilos every
week you're gonna cut it a little bit
and you're gonna make eight drop-offs a
week then you're gonna pick up cash from
a people legitimately you don't think
this coke dealer in Hollywood that's
been so uncomfortable like Nicholson I'm
sure there ain't this guy and that guy
and that guy that nobody even knows his
name okay
haven't you always did like that the
story like people get pulled over for a
broken taillight like do something
happen you with your Oh like when you're
using that you become a pro you find
high spots like you'd learn to cut your
pants right there by the zipper and you
put it in and it's like you know where
they're gonna search you and not find it
listen to me and hooli well I got in
trouble for what I did right there were
two factors that will make me lose from
the start hey I was doing it over an
addiction and be the three people
involved with [ __ ] amateurs
there's no way on earth if I was in the
straight way I would have done business
with these two [ __ ] morons especially
especially the Tidwell character I can't
even describe
therefore z'gok our the Tidwell
character - yeah like I can't even
describe he was a white dude that in
hindsight now you could tell something
wasn't right like his dad beat him I got
he was that Corey Feldman he huh and he
was not at me he was not handsome I felt
kinda bad from I worked in him for about
four months and how I met him was I
bought weed every Thursday when I got
paid he was well he was a weed dealer at
the body shop this is like what old swag
weed and [ __ ] like this was great we did
here this is Colorado weed that was
phenomenal he had two different types of
weed payday he float me one and then I'm
paid dad buy another one and you know it
was a lot like that he was very good to
me and then I got when I went this to
sell cars
there were guys that wanted weed and
bulk and I would go to him and I'd make
a little profit in between but then the
cocaine came when I would go to him from
time to time and he was getting this
yellow chunk the strip club in Denver
hell that would make your [ __ ] hair
stand up uh he kept giving it to me I
know how much this [ __ ] does your guy
got he goes he's got 20 pounds of it so
we started talking this one on few years
I will now the guy who had a small Buick
with tinted windows and the rims were
done he had a loud stereo he was floss
okay this is 87 he had tattoos already
our hongwol mother Jackie will bite the
shoes he had a pitbull okay we had a
Harley he he did everything that he
could to fit it okay to that world yeah
he was like a no no he would talk to
people as this he were
yeah can you give me that weed well I'm
gonna speak to my partners you know he
was how I was well those white dudes
that made himself more important than
what he was yeah cocaine of that well
let me make a call don't feel my
partner's yeah I don't know if that
plane landed yet I don't know he was one
of those [ __ ] sure ah but I let him
play his game he always delivered and he
was a half a [ __ ] but what do you
want from me you know I'm saying yeah
that's the people involved in this
business when I met him bald but then it
got ugly George he would come to me
looking for to sell he knew I could sell
[ __ ] from yeah he knew you actually one
day he goes I'll cut you a better deal
and he was always solid and at that time
I worked at an American Indian do it
American Indians what's that
he sold cars cars with a garlic he was
an American he looked like one of your
cousin's everything speak Spanish okay
they had a mohawk all right that's what
it was all right I got you now when you
apply for [ __ ] 23andme have you spent
the bottle yet now go go when all the
23andme let them send you to what is
23andme they figure out your DNA
that shit's all bunk I seen it like this
guy spit in two things and what it was a
white girl one said she was African know
that she was European
it depends would dick you suck the night
before she's in the head that she sucked
a black dick a week before that [ __ ]
stays with you dear then I fail you I'll
do it
but check it out my guarantee there's
like a picture Johnny Sanchez is uncle
with a bow and arrow I know I got
Indiana videos so my point is that
he just wasn't the sharpest tool in the
shed but he came into my life at a time
when a guy came to me it's like a guy
coming to me like I can't even say Lee I
have to say somebody who's a little
wiser but I knew I could take them oh I
know what you mean this guy came to
meeting his brother on a big time bond I
got a DUI this guy was a class act he
got a lot of this guy well he was
creative I worked at this guy for about
two months and every day was the day
lately how I talked to you twice a week
is how he would go every day like as
soon as you got the [ __ ] work at 8:30
there was an employee meeting yeah you
got like a bagel a cup of coffee I'm hot
on her and right from there he's he
already plotted out how he was gonna get
the booze for the day Wayne was a good
cocaine and who was smoking the first
joint behind the building oh [ __ ] so I
would let him go because I don't get
high in the daytime I was there to sell
cars so for him he had all of the two or
three guys and that's all they did is
there a lot of cocaine using for car
sales oh my god yeah I could have I work
at that first place I worked at it was
at the first management I worked with
that the guy that ran the place was the
fearless leader he was snorting up a
spawn all right and there was one dude
who wasn't that was a doing bumps but he
wasn't doing it and he was my mentor at
the time there was a couple of white
dudes that didn't do it but every other
sales were there there was two Indian
dudes that were brothers that were big
like 48 hours there was a medium white
dude
the old dudes got down from 8:30 in the
morning till nine o'clock at night just
like moving it was a crazy yeah that was
like a that was like a weird place that
was like a weird place every place had
their little problems so I said [ __ ] it
I went to a [ __ ] chrysler-plymouth
store is that another dealership - two
miles down beautiful was a Dodge and on
the other side of the
chrysler-plymouth Dodds had eight
salesmen chrysler-plymouth had three and
they were looking for what the manager
was an old Jew from New York named our
Pressler okay slick [ __ ] didn't
look it verily
look likely only 54 little older with a
beard very he had been their fav months
and he took the Salesforce from 22 cars
a month to 50 a month
oh and he liked me because I was from
New York and he goes you'll keep me
company I'm dealing with all these white
bucks out here you know I don't know
what a [ __ ] bagel is in the oh yeah
at that at that place bro within two
weeks when I got down like finally I'm
at a place bro that I'm the only junkie
I feel what they don't know it because
I'm not coming in here jumped up when I
leave here I go home and get junked up
even if I stay up til 4:00 I jerk off
and I show up at 8:30 and I'm fine
I'm twenty [ __ ] five yeah you're
hopeful I don't know I don't know that's
twenty five hours sleep in two hours in
a week I know you working out working
all day lift some weights drinking
snorting I was gonna say how much are
you snorting at the time if I was not if
I weigh that that to him if I was
storing a half gram a night and I was
drinkin ight and I would drink three
cocktails at Red Robin uh-huh
but then something happened Pro one of
the dudes that worked there Rob I
started saying sniffle and then it was
his own adieu one day a customer came in
and it was his turn he goes I can't take
him right now
and when I walked in there could tell
his joy was gone
uh he was [ __ ] hangs from like two
for two
this is kind of weird and there was a
white dude that was half Indian he was
the guy that was getting weed from the
reservation know how I was giving him
weed I was what I got hooked up with
this do cuz I wanted this car dealership
this is crazy that you have an Indian a
Jew from York I do from New York that
was a sales manager then there was four
offices so there was four salesmen one
white dude look like Lee Harvey Oswald
all right he looked just like Lee Harvey
Oswald he acted like him I think his
name was John Harvey then the other guy
was a white dude but he was really an
American Indian and he knew people up at
the [ __ ] Indian board yeah I thought I
could then the other do was an Italian
dude that was from like Chicago that was
a tremendous salesman but he was a coach
at and a half oh and then there was me
but I kept my drug secret at that point
out of there yeah you were like a ninja
until I saw I saw the Italian dude coked
up and I saw the white dude coked up and
now I'm something was up at this place
so pretty soon I got the fight I got the
scoop of it somebody offered me a bump I
did it the next day you know was a hair
in and I asked him how do I get some
more than I look there he goes go to
heart my heart's table that's like
George Perez give me three bumps I know
who you get this [ __ ] coke from he
goes li-huei to say yeah you don't get
this coke from laser smart [ __ ]
Lee had taken me by that point this dual
arm wrestler I mean that was a great car
salesman but I didn't know that the
basics and I didn't mean I was a street
salesman so I could sell you anything
but he slow me down
has shown me the basic basics how to
really suck him in like a true fisherman
oh my god this guy was a genius and he
goes listen since I got here this guy
was a bum he's making eight grand a
month
Wow that guy was a killer he was being
an egrants already he's making 16 grand
and the other dude he was a bomb he was
making two grand a month honor he's
making four he goes of you do what you
do one's ten cause I'll make you
anywhere from seven to ten thousand a
month if you do it my way to the book
and bro it took everything in my power
for me to do it exactly all he would say
but I made more money than ever
those three months like though you're
averaging a month
when I was at Subaru I was probably
selling 15 the 16 cars and making $7,000
a month
[ __ ] that's a lot in 88 ok at Hollister
I was selling eight cars and making
$9,000 plus my car was for free oh I
think the Lea I get with insurance Lea
just one shot free as long as I saw
seven colors the car was free and every
month I could drive it in and go you
know what kind of want to drive this
display I want a voyage whoa it was like
steam hard-pressed well maybe art of
[ __ ] and selling cause and the next
thing you know this dude says to me you
didn't know thought already my heart
broke it was like when I found that that
Joe Montana did cocoa he does I boys a
big ask ok yeah that's why he gets to
come back power from flower tart one day
I wouldn't even talk to him about it I
would send other people to get the quote
from already for me just one out of like
two or three months his coke was on fire
dog and he was getting it from the dude
but I watched him for like three months
I watched it his game was his game was
basic he would get it from somewhere and
he would drop off three ounces on you go
see you next month yeah I need that I
need that 2,400 because it he comes in
the first two look I nobody do nothing
[ __ ] unbelievable the way you watch
it hat Oh dog it's happened to me at
work like I've worked at so many strip
clubs and every strip club has like
their own drug dealer that like the
girls trust the manager trust he could
you know that he Isis the [ __ ] the
door guy after a I throw some to me then
you know what I mean he takes care of it
then now he's in ok so when he gives you
that money what does that mean what it
would I get any money he's giving me
cocaine years of a package
oh he goes a man if you like it let
everybody know here here's some more huh
yeah hey you know me I'm not giving it
I'm selling it to these [ __ ] I'm
gonna a try this out try this out and
it's it's [ __ ] crazy man I've seen it
at strip clubs I've seen it at bars I
remember one time I went to like a movie
screen and we were in downtown LA and we
we go to this bar and that's when I
realized [ __ ] from LA don't
care this fool just put it in the dollar
right there goes here isn't it that now
as I do right by the bar how am I
supposed to sniff that leave the world
of the drug dealer and spread let's
strike him right let me
what are you [ __ ] all day what's the
closest bar round that you would
actually enter big Wang's big Wang's big
Wang's has two drug dealers waitress
down how her friend is a coke dealer now
she brings the lane border to work every
night or she steals from him it makes
her money cause she's a hustler no no no
no she's legit because she'll go back in
the middle and then get more and then
you have the dog I wanted a dog a half
go okay they sold for the staff at first
but it's it's the way of the business I
recently went to a bar okay
I recently returned a month ago one
night but four weeks ago five weeks ago
no why state changes I went to a bar
there's a dear friend of mine owns so I
sat there i welcomed his family welcomed
me up above a bar now there's a little
restaurant but on the other side of it
it's a bar and it's it's guys that of me
now that I'm 5410 me at 22 so as I walk
in I feel it I sit in the back I make
believe I don't know nothing footballs
on the effluence a Saturday I said I
wants the bars got maybe 30 deep they're
yelling again
this Agreement I haven't seen this guy
in about three years for hisa tober he
always fools for me the other comedian
or watching that I flip over I think you
know what I don't want to sit with my
back to the door let me flip this way
man watch the bar and there was two hot
blonde the bartenders beautiful cleavage
no big deal now and there was a door guy
and there was a [ __ ] two bathrooms
dog
I watched six drug deals go down and
five of them were one guy and one of
them was with a cheque that you would
have sat there all day lead and would
not have seen a thing happened just
because that was me
we know the world we know the world go
see how it happened you know it's like
and then we see the girl that's with you
that you brought in that you met at the
like that's how I caught it you know how
I caught it with the weakest link in the
thing a guy comes in that works with a
chick
uh-huh that's gonna suck his dick but he
doesn't know that she's a junkie oh okay
so you better at the [ __ ] movie
theater she comes in with you and why
you drink and she goes oh my god I lost
my ATM card can I borrow 50 bucks on
melee and I'll get with you tomorrow
yeah no I'd yeah you give her the fifty
and I saw her I can run over make
believe she was doing something
make-believe she was talking to a
waitress then she told me she had on
give her 50 bucks that was his sister
and then she went through a drug deal
and I saw her go to the bathroom come
back kissed the guy on the cheek the guy
thought he was getting [ __ ] you don't
know he's already minus 50 yeah he's
already minus 2/5 I mean it's [ __ ]
crazy how you saying it and no matter
what bar you gonna if you go to if I
send you tomorrow leader where'd you go
Lompoc if you're gonna Lompoc and you
sit at Lompoc at 5 o'clock and you go
over you with a backpack right or you
have the egg out of man out back till
you'll sit out back at the boss
and people come in that come in there
every [ __ ] night and within an hour
you'll see something irregular you'll
see something irregular and it helps the
bar the Queen your bar turn the wants at
the listen a bar owner wants to know
believe doesn't want to know he will
yeah he doesn't want to know he doesn't
want to know it keeps everybody drinking
it keeps everybody drinking so if you
guys see it why don't the cop see it
they don't give a [ __ ] they're not
really caring huh so water because even
if they come in there Liam they goalie I
thought detective Diaz there's anything
illegal to you here at 9:00 you know do
you see activity here have you ever seen
this guy mr. Perez in here you mean
George George George Perez is a
gentleman he comes in by he's a [ __ ]
taco every no no no why [ __ ] kill you
yeah it's like if you go to a bowling
alley there's all these [ __ ] 24 and
over kids they're selling the does annex
the EBC pills
the oxycottons the ecstasy that you see
pill that's those new pills that they
come out they're called triple stack
[ __ ] like eight are there's drugs right
now that like my son like showed me that
look [ __ ] are trying to drug me
brought on this triple stacked iron man
I don't know what I did a [ __ ] listen
our buddies mine I haven't seen him in
six years gave me a hug and a comedy
show and he goes how you doing and we
talked and he has people want to do a
line in this hotel unless I don't do
that [ __ ] no more I know this
[ __ ] Houston day somehow I do
date a black chick Eddie goes what are
you gonna do after the hotel listen I
have fun go to bed because uh I only got
catch a flight at 4:30 brother I'm sorry
I didn't know you were coming we lost
contact
so he talked to ten more minutes ago G
ones that accept or whatever you got so
he gave me two of those antics is the
same ones I get the white ones but then
they gave me the circle poem with T
something on it some three letters okay
you didn't tell you otherwise no I go
what is this he looks like a baby Viper
[Laughter]
I took the [ __ ] comes Alex just put them
in my own thing of the baby vitamin I
don't touch that baby Micah until one
that I wasn't there for his antics
before the Kombi store and there's a
baby Viking I go what am i doing
tomorrow it was like yeah let's take a
chance and I fell that night and that's
the way I'm Laurel Canyon I popped it by
the time I got home nothing and then
about an hour later I started getting
this water bro warmth yeah like this
warp came up ah this is good and within
20 minutes brought a rash everywhere at
least that's what it felt like I
scratched from head to fat and tone I've
been there I go oh my god then I lay
down and my wife finally said what you
got him put some powder on cuz I was
scratched and everything my feet my neck
that's embarassing the next day you're
walking around with [ __ ] band-aids on
your face look [ __ ] you they're like my
little [ __ ] xanax about the road will
you got a three-hour difference as an ex
from Nike I never took a xanax me either
bro there's so many different [ __ ]
thing animals out there I gotta be
careful because of the [ __ ] sleep
apnea you know what the rapper just
passed away from what you say his sleep
apnea no no whoo what rep rep 21 year
old YouTube kid he's 21 year old YouTube
kid is not a rapper in my world it was a
rapper too listen if I'm if I'm with a
woman and we start snorting Friday at
2:00 in the morning we go back to our
house and we got both of us she got a
quarter round sang on the corner else
and we'll go Saturday night worrying
xanax I give out dick hearts yeah oh
yeah I had to get some blood her [ __ ]
and then
zabbix gets the blood right to the
clintus tremendous value Ice Cube with a
couple of flicks of the finger and then
money jab actor wife next thing you know
you know what man you look down the next
morning and you've eat a jar and ethics
ah and people do that all the time his
count is that well Lamar Odom was doing
when he was over there in the hotel in
Vegas I heard he was on xanax cocaine
and you read the xanax like every hour
on the hour
why don't fall kid gorilla was like I
was doing yeah yeah like first down at
the football game lines like that oh
your [ __ ] and gorilla [ __ ] lives like
a guy like myself did I'm very guilty of
that and you're popping xanax like one
an hour because you got a hot chick then
you want to get some so the Zags can get
it's like a viagra you're telling me I
don't in my world it at least kept
through the ball game Sonic's got hard
and I wouldn't come
oh that for two hours like 20 minutes no
six minutes if I stay alive for six
minutes like the flipper movie - let's
take a finger there muffled it's over
jizz on the neck oh my I'm there do a
couple more bubs they suck your horn
move on whatever I don't [ __ ] know
I'm just using my generation is a you
just buy some [ __ ] oh man I remember
doing some [ __ ] cocaine off like
titties and belly buttons I remember one
time we did it off this bitch's pants
because it fell in her pocket so we
[ __ ] took the stitching off the
pocket with the razor and like the
pocket was here and ah dah everything
was up there you know laid off [ __ ]
pieces of Petty's nosov Lincoln's face
that [ __ ] burned my brain nothing cuz
you know there was probably detergent I
was dry it in there - it burned my brain
some men I snorted [ __ ] off bathrooms
you know I see wanted stuff changing
tables you know you don't know whether
it's sheetrock you don't know if it's
the the little sponge white foam that
this you just don't know it's 5:00 in
the morning
you're just scraping [ __ ] pens and
pencils number one the BIC you would
take the thing out and snore it then
give a light yeah you white and you get
great but I does get a little less line
yeah you know I'm the reason em claiming
we did creepy [ __ ] [ __ ] that I keep
close to my heart because I never want
to do that again yeah I saved like 20
baggies once you know how the bag he has
a resin and I got a [ __ ] razor and I
[ __ ] scratched it down I had like two
big old lines
oh how scandalous the way my heart was
beating when I was cutting it that
building I lived that Hollywood had an
elevator then I would call the dealer
and I would run to the elevator and go
down to the first one run down and get
the coke and at this time I wouldn't
even like I wasn't saving coke yeah I
was in hoarding coke I would have in my
pocket already a rolled up dollar or the
piece of scotch tape on it and why
because as I was walking up into the
elevator
I was already grinding the coconut benzo
ah ok and I wouldn't press number four
until all the coke was grinded and once
I pressed them before the bender was
open and the dollar bill was already in
so by the time I got to the fourth floor
the whole package was gonna at that time
I wasn't doing coke like normally at the
end Philippe came on and he told the
story about but I vividly I knew
Philippe had a problem at this time I
had a horrible problem but Philippe I'd
be up wait yeah he claimed he would hide
it from you we will hide it from each
other yeah because I knew that he was
somewhere else for that like me Felipe
is the type of dude that gets high and
I'll take the [ __ ] Hill get in the
car with Lee and go to a party yeah the
a go for the morning yeah I'm not gonna
fall - I don't do that type of [ __ ] my
business I'll stay home with your girl
go ahead you go I'll stay home as I got
older yeah you don't think you realize
that no no no no he's never one of those
guys what here we're good yeah I'm good
I've been that guy yeah well here
another party and then people try to
[ __ ] totally pay believe through people
in four in the morning with different
people from we're all together and all
some where's Philippe he left with those
three Mexican dudes okay god bless him
he never even came and checked it and I
don't people people I'm talking about
2001 Felipe 2002 Philippe Luiz due
Wednesday nights then at that [ __ ]
place - crazy place so mm-hmm
we're told wile coyote doing coke or
some song okay so it's gotta be 2006 how
about a [ __ ] cocaine Ted I got a call
from Felipe one that early for early
yeah you had to answer a the clock
that's my brother
yeah I always answer the phone now at
this time I had heard his about his
stories and he always do I snorted coke
there's no wine between us so I met him
I know compadre he doesn't say nothing
the whole lot we were there I got a
cocktail I got a package I do a few
lines and if you know anything about me
I would always get the backup package
mm-hmm and that goes in the medicine
chest the top pocket oh yeah it's just
in case the night gets nice the cops
chase you they'll check that pocket hair
you know there's always - here take that
one that's only got two lines it will do
you knowing that I have the G boat
grinder look deep deep deep deep deep in
that pot by the zipper [ __ ] always a so
you're at the bar Oh Felipe I'm at the
ball Philippe at them
hola whatever the [ __ ] el compadre and
he goes I go Felipe I gotta go home I
don't only do two lines in public and
that's that I gotta called me [ __ ] and
do this packet hey I got finally he said
father the people there's nobody I
really want to meet you know I'm saying
so I'll never forget getting in this car
and right in front of him he was driving
bro right I'll never forget being by the
gas station on sunset mothers by the
stripclub crazy girls mm-hmm being at
that light on sunset going east and me
taking the the package I bought there
that night and just doing the whole
[ __ ] live licking it and throwing
that package out the window and having
the backup package and him am I talking
and I could tell that he wants to ask me
yeah and if I can I have do you have
anything on you and I'm playing like I'm
done that that was why just for up sorry
and he looked at me because I can't
believe you did that
I go bro that's how I roll so the car
starts going now we get over by though
with chick-fil-a is said in Highland we
passed that way that though and as we
[ __ ] pass that I go my little
undercover package and he's driving me
telling me about his future he's going
with the rover Gabriel blah blah blah I
take it another package out I opened
that one up with phone and his eyes
light up I put the dollar bill in there
again and as he's making the turn up to
my block I do the whole [ __ ] thing in
one one yeah
and we're getting in front of my house
he goes did you save me I go no and I
would never give it to you anyway and I
should you saying game with kiss that
one stairs probably hit from that wife
for an hour and they [ __ ] did my
thing [ __ ] the crazy
that's how long and all these cats man
yeah I remember back in that one I first
met you I used to hide her from you too
but I knew you knew
and I just I knew you liked the fact
that I respected you to hide it from you
that was like we were scared of you dog
like you were the one we respected and
hid it from
no because I never wanted because you
had the best stories I remember you're
in Texas and I guess you hit the cocaine
in the water and you forgot and you
drank the [ __ ] water
I remember you telling me that story I
hit the cup no hey hey hey I [ __ ]
well I do I was in the hotel room in
Denver
yeah was Denver bro my buddies left coke
you know you ever go to a hotel room bro
and they [ __ ] have a tissue paper
thing in the wall yeah
they called me and said we left you two
key we had get on a plane get there
before the [ __ ] maid and run up that
as a Do Not Disturb sign we left you the
key show me an ID and run up there in
the war there's a full ounce of coke we
didn't even touch it I went up there
brothers a full house at oh ah I ran
down the stairs I got in the cab and I
ran to this little [ __ ] dingy hotel
you know 20 hours a night maybe after
Tony why not stay at the nice hotel
because I'm doing blow yeah you does
this Pablo Escobar yeah I had a
girlfriend who lived in Boulder whoever
ended up being my future wife I call her
from the hotel room lingo hey I gotta
have your coat
love this hotel room in Boulder in
Denver she goes where yeah like tell us
she goes listen I'm in school till 5:00
I'll call you when I get out and I'll
come down this is how much were freed
that was 1987 this has to be I kid them
a lot of [ __ ] coke dog dog the whole
[ __ ] house you ready for this
afternoon yeah now it's 11:00 in the
morning over this hotel room maybe I got
12 beers that's that's that's good for
couple hours no cigarettes and uh no
cigarettes no weed at the time I had
weed but I wasn't smoking the hotel room
physic ops okay oh my god this is a
horrible story I get in the room I lock
the door another
two minutes I take this outside it's
perfect I mean it George it's perfect
it's like a crater it is perfect it's
chunky it's flaky it's fresh flaky and
it smells of ether it's it's in two bags
I take it out these guys are left with
four ounces on a Sunday and got to
Denver on a Wednesday they had stopped
in st. Louis and they took flight stand
and sleep the whole time
ah they slept and they finally fell
asleep in Denver for three hours and the
one kids mother was looking for him all
across the country she finally called me
as she goes did he call you he was here
for Sunday dinner and they left and they
never came back my buddies were crazy
then this is four years after I left
they go to his hotel room I calm who was
my girlfriend and I didn't know nobody
else bro
so I special on little lines I'm
watching TV they had a porno channel
yeah then I'm watching a porno channel
I'm jerking off I'm drinking my little
beers
I'm slowing cook but I knew I kind of
had a warrant in Snowmass privilege so I
kind of went into my head so I got a
rare enjoy so guess what I started
hearing the drill
I started hearing drills and all four
walls so I took the blow and I hit in
the medicine chest in the [ __ ] hotel
room I'm do a little bumps looking at
myself in the mirror and fixing myself
choice and then nothing on the phones
ringing do you want room service
and now I know the FBI's looking awesome
so now I'm on [ __ ] fire but I don't
give a [ __ ] I'm doing this blog dog just
porn is good it's two white guys they
got a chick tied up and they're about to
stab but before they make us suck that
dick I mean I got a jerkwad I was crazy
choice and also the sudden makes me go
to the back window this was a nice cheap
hotel that the back gonna have like bars
you don't tell us all those okay was the
third floor and then I remember it was
like I like this like an oval but when I
looked over Joy's there was a car park
yeah and then four minutes later my car
would go into a bridge and another car
would pull up oh and this is going on
every five minutes so now my mind's an
overdrive I'm hearing drills I turn the
Polo off I'm sitting on the bed listen
to see if I see a drill come through the
wall and then they put the scope back
through your wall yes so I [ __ ] I
look around I'm the [ __ ] room when I
go [ __ ] this and there's little desk
wall little container where you can fill
up with ice so I went my fill deliver
water from the [ __ ] sink and I took
it in the coke was gorgeous the cocaine
was gorgeous it was gorgeous Brown was a
junkie I had been offered for about four
days and he ha how it falls on my lap
and it was in like gram chunks and I
took it and it was shaved when you
popped it the whole room smelled like it
that's aa piece of the coke and I threw
in this water to see how long it would
take to dissolve in case the cops
knocked on when I go out to 3 grams you
say to three games I took him maybe I
don't know
Oh guys twelve ounces of water maybe and
I took another chunk that was like
another two grams like to run again in
the water to see how long it would take
to dissolve because I wanted to sit on
the bed watch the porn with the volume
off and I was going to sit this
Northcote and just jerk off now this
time the phone's ringing it's my
girlfriend bulb but she wants to know
what the [ __ ] going on it's five
o'clock now I'm too high guess what
I don't even wanna that bro I got about
22 grams of coke yeah I'm doing this on
my own
she's gonna come over here and talk oh
yeah I'm gonna [ __ ] his [ __ ] we're gonna
do some freaky [ __ ] and it's gonna fail
wait he's not gonna leave so this coke
is gone yeah they followed me [ __ ] her
and the horse who sent her and she's
calling me because she took my brother
we'll take a half hour off you can make
some money and I'm like no I got a
chance of making 900 bucks or snort in
the shower I kept snoring George and
snortin and I hear the drills and
finally at one point George's about 17
grams of coke and I'm doing so much of
it in the bathroom just take it I'm
holding the mother what can tell me what
that is
that's what Joey has yeah oh my god I'm
taking it and I'm putting it in my nose
but it's falling all over the bathroom
floor Sartre one point I just take them
back yeah flush the toilet and I throw
the coke in the toilet and I look at it
dissolve but I flushed it aha and the
toilet I could see the coke sticking to
the side of the toilet so now I'm
looking out the window and cars are
still pulling up to the thing and
switching I'm hearing drills the phone's
[ __ ] ringing and I'm looking for coke
now because I'm coming down and I'm
finding it all over the bathroom floor
there's a path in on the way to the room
I'm walking in stuffing coke in my nose
and I'm jerking off and watch the curb
it's seven o'clock at night the phone's
ringing
the lights red red red like you know
this is the 80s the lights [ __ ]
flashing you know
I'm waiting for the knock on the door so
I could kill her but guess what even if
she shows up there's no Coke left it's
in the toilet bro
so I nailed by the toilet and every spot
that was yellow I would stick my finger
in the toilet oh well I did that's all
about 3:00 in the morning then I went in
the shower taped off were you having fun
oh yeah that's a pirate junkie when
you're a junkie oh my god that was as
fun as it gets I should have had a clown
come over bulls that was one of the most
demoralizing times of my lively plus I
blew $1,800 oh my god that's a Tina
dollar profit you flush but here's what
gets best there's more I go to sleep you
fell asleep I fell asleep like that day
for two hours the phone rings it's Kathy
what did you do it to coke listen just
come get me okay I'll be there an hour
hang up the phone
I get up I look around the room and all
there is a pitcher of water next to me I
pick up the [ __ ] water and I drink
the whole thing good good good good good
good good oh my god I get the half of it
I start to taste cocaine strong numbness
in your dumb that I dress the whole
thing and then I go to [ __ ] hit the
door locks it's Kathy and I can't talk
but there's the cocaine that I drank the
four grams I put in that water
just like shut down my throat you ever
do a lot of coke and your voice changes
oh yeah yeah you're nervous you're
scared
my father my voice went away I lost my
voice for the day so I ended up blowing
$1,800 I mean it was just a disaster all
around now that was 1986 so how long ago
was that 41 years no 31 at 31 years my
bad guess what do you know the
[ __ ] I left the coconut wall
that night hit me up on Facebook about
three years ago that huh
like oh god no way I swear to God that's
some [ __ ] up [ __ ] right but what -
look what how long does he have to ask
you for that it was crazy because he
left the coconut war it's not like I
said to leave the coconut wall okay
he left the coke in the wall I get a
call at that time I didn't have a phone
guys I lifted my girlfriend sister and
her family and 11 o'clock at night the
house phone rings it's my ex-wife my
girlfriend's in time but she calls she
goes I grab a pen so they know what's up
she described this number your friends
are in Denver at the airport then what
are you talking about English yet I want
you to call him I think his name is
hello Danny
psycho case right [ __ ] get over Cole
I called Danny at the airport Coke's
where are you he doesn't sit here with
SABS and Russo it's a party
you know what we'll load up we'll load
it up we got everything you need
get in the [ __ ] car meet us at the
airport I get my [ __ ] car I get gas
and take a shower
I Drive wrong with that man when I get
there and like three guys come up there
like a you Coco yeah there's a note
they couldn't wait they went to a strip
club the best one in Denver
get in the car I go down there I get in
there there they are brother running a
table let's go hello bills with these
chicks
[ __ ] yeah all motormouth they're [ __ ]
up deaf [ __ ] up I'm like wait a
[ __ ] guy stayed like the hotel across
the street we got two wells it's a blow
over there we're gonna pick up ten
chicks and bring them over in a little
party and I'm like you guys are [ __ ]
crazy we'll have Danny be coy what did
he be calling my buddy the one who
Thomas was I'm gonna forget yeah I think
it's Danny be SABS
and [ __ ] in the Tommy yeah do me inside
dick Eddie went to a bar once and did so
much coke that we paid the strippers to
leave us alone because my dick wouldn't
get hard I was like a here's a books
just leave don't it like you're gonna
clown us we couldn't get hard for [ __ ]
and then the strippers do not
cos she was trying to like kiss me and I
move and like a [ __ ] rock fell out on
the table you know how that [ __ ] is she
licked it up oh this is good [ __ ]
one time I [ __ ] up and I gave a
stripper my sack oh yeah that's a change
I hate let me get a bump that [ __ ] that
[ __ ] came back empty is [ __ ] like the
[ __ ] dollar or never give a chick a
package to come back especially a
stripper you tell them to go in the
bathroom which into the men's bathroom I
would love it to one of those [ __ ]
urinals I don't give a [ __ ] why are we
in it cuz you're gonna do two bumps then
you gonna watch me piss this is pre
louis c.k women I went to a bathroom
with to do coke
I dare thought I was personal friends
with a boo-boo and then they're like do
me a favor
I got a pee turn around and you're
standing on oh my god a woman just
pulled the pants on right behind me yeah
I went to the bathroom 20 times in my
life a woman that was friends with who
said well we're in here let me just be
turning around and I would turn over I
would never paint in front of a [ __ ]
one without Romy yo put some Tony
Bennett on together sit there like a bun
I thought off your [ __ ] phone what's
the matter with you that's the last
thing you want you [ __ ] a pulled low
by mistake god forbid top it's cute oh
my you know they got you hooked up with
somebody I don't even know no that's not
me that's my old drug dealer going
please come back dawg
you can laugh off no no I can just
imagine you good custom I've seen
explain to him you'll say that's a
brilliant way I would gain your
customers back [ __ ] the tweet [ __ ] the
text let me show you a picture the
qualia bullet rollover yeah I imagine if
drugs at his face time that the lab will
slip you [ __ ] oh I didn't even
tell you something I always you don't
well if I snorted coke know how
different it would be we'll all be able
to computer know everything
I mean right now you'd be a [ __ ] fool
no you don't think that UPS is said
they're from saying the AH straight up
two spots in Chicago
you've got rocks in your [ __ ] head
they have to battle then the Mules what
every stars you got left Lee give me six
eight four so I was the other two right
here
you got a match I made six I'm fine um
you're a savage what Lee what what what
don't you think you do even better now
because you couldn't do it without the
computer I think the computer leaves too
much of a trail I think you'd do better
the old school way hey Alan I don't
think in the drugs anyway but I'm just
saying one thing and any drug dealer
could do the better it's just really
weird how just because your life Doug
doesn't mean which I made a living when
I was in there all straight out I went
when I was in there within seven days I
figured out you can only have $20 in
your pocket at one time because number I
want already had done a month in County
so that counts two for one right mm-hmm
I got four months 48 months they cut it
right away the 24 months that's all you
gotta do yeah half time
so half time I had already done one in
County which counts for two yeah
that's 22 so I was already that was -
what's eligible for a halfway house I
know exactly what you mean that's a
Mints homely you're following me yeah
yeah they sent me the detention has more
[ __ ] drugs there they sent me to a
detention to do the week of seminars
they take blood from you and they ask
you creepy questions about what do you
think about this picture is [ __ ] watch
I'm home boy it is that's a week of
[ __ ] I forget what the [ __ ] they
call it so they put everybody runs
through there that week
yeah that's 23-hour lockdown I think
it's called fur lowers its four weeks
it's uh it's until you figure out where
they're gonna send diagnostic diagnostic
thank you for me it was called
diagnostic markup have my buddy there
was locked up to that went to he told me
exactly what to do when I got the
diagnostic he told me exactly who to go
to give him a message and then
everything would be cool I went to him
they gave me things they want to put me
in to sell me I walked right over those
little don't put him in and that was it
I didn't talk to the guy again for about
a week but they put me downstairs
and I didn't understand that they put me
on the first floor there was [ __ ] six
floors it was Colorado was last six
floors it was August 15th it's 90
[ __ ] degrees and this bottom of where
diagnostic is now but I'll then it was
hot it was it was kind of hot on the
first floor but now we'll it would be
like on the sixth floor and that's the
place where people would yell all night
yo Tyrone what up well you wouldn't they
busted you yeah over at big money house
they killed big money but I got away
it's all night way yeah people trying to
translate messages holes here roll call
yeah Lee it's all night the fur and
you're sleeping at a metal bed you're in
a little toilet by yourself there's a
sheet between you and the metal bed and
the skinny sheet on you but it's a
different experience for a guy like you
and a guy like me who wouldn't have
never been to prison before yeah that
was my first time in prison we saw
you've been to jail before that was
County Jail County Jail and prisons
house there's no difference in my hand
oh yeah yes the differences County Jail
this cops around yell all times got
visitation your attorney comes to you
you're putting the cell by yourself you
have a cell block you read the paper you
eat dinner with other inmates you don't
really say much
you don't belong to nobody nobody knows
your paperwork
luckily like it's a big difference and
you're gonna make bail yeah when you're
in the county you don't have a release
date you're in there fighting to know
when you're gonna go home there's a
different person in you well you go to
prison you know when you're going home
you have to you now in blue like its
life now you have to get the [ __ ] up
there's no sheriff's there to save your
ass it's it's the real deal huh
so do it or lose you want to do as long
as no no no thank you
so you wonder as long in County as you
can no because at the same time the
county doesn't have [ __ ] for you it's
there's no people are only there for
nine months or two years fighting cases
like it gets flipped so much you rather
be in the county because you don't have
a sheriff on your ass
those sheriff's know that you that
you're gonna be gone when you're in
prison those cops are way cooler not
that they're even cool but it's just a
respect they know you live there and you
know you you develop a working
relationship
and they know exactly your limitations
or what you'll do and if you're cool and
you don't have a past those limitations
bro they don't [ __ ] with you your
cigarettes in prison there's no
cigarettes in the county that shit's
hard when I was in County that's how old
I am
Boulder would give you a pack of rolled
cigarettes oh my god you know that when
I got locked up and then I got I got up
and I started calming and 91 and I want
to contest in 92 I would be because it
was I had a write new material
every [ __ ] Tuesday George it was bold
broker steak night comedy night for $15
you got a steak a big potato salad that
sounds bottled a ticket to a comedy show
you know how hard it was to talk people
to eat the steak so look at you you have
any idea I forgot the one you couldn't
go there with the same material every
week now so every week I would write
something down for the newspaper and
talk about it and one of the best jokes
I had in the very beginning was that
Boulder Colorado was voted the number
two jail in the country behind another
cut County Jail and a Charlaine out
Sonora no the one it was
another jail so Boulder was dumb but
Boulder was number two on the top ten
county jails they didn't like women a
four out of five dentists surveyed yeah
it was something like that to him when
you read it do you want to dial after
like anal intense inmates surveyed that
did to retire in three different county
jails that Boulder County Jail was the
second best thing I mean it was crazy
number one was another place in Colorado
but that there air conditioner and fans
that's probably a federal pair with no
no no no no it was a county jail oh wow
the top ten county jails in the country
they treat their [ __ ] row had the
best food I ever had number three on
Thanksgiving dinner forget the guy left
the cell open and you can do as many
calls as you wanted I was a [ __ ] 2:00
in the morning HBO bolded it and [ __ ]
around Wow built the new one and they
took the cigarettes away and they took
the then you could weigh your own
clothes away yeah that's our point oh
there was a time week away your own
clothes Lee
like I said they don't happen all
morning no Jim it's too much [ __ ] going
down you know it's crazy - is it now
that Thanksgiving is coming up I spent
three [ __ ] Thanksgivings in prison
how were they dog it was the first one
sucked because I was new I don't know
what the [ __ ] was going on I was just
happy because they gave you a real
drumstick the ice cream bar at the end
for dessert
I like those yeah so then I started
working in the kitchen and then now they
would give us a big-ass turkey leg but
the [ __ ] inmates didn't know how to
cook them right all the time so like I
had to have a bi son let me up I sell
wood grill it for me on his ship
oh by the grill what would they make a
grill other ok so a grill oh man like a
lot of these guys were key electrical so
that it going the electrical they put it
in their cart and like the homie would
break the tile or something in there
where we needed that cart to come into
our dorm for repair so he would sneak it
into the cart fix it and man I'm trying
to like think of what he made out of
this thing like he made this thing that
would warm up that he would plug it into
the wall and it would [ __ ] war I
think he used the bottoms of the coffee
there's coffee now you put the coffee
pots there genius
yeah the genius these guys what's the
difference between paisa and homie
a by sana homie a homie is someone
that's uh from America a paisa could be
someone that's from Cuba Mexico Honduras
El Salvador okay yeah you're a paisa to
us all right that's the that's all I'm a
homey no no you're another another yeah
you or your white but I don't think the
errands are really gonna like you no
they're not
I still remember the Mexican dudes face
I still 30 years later the Mexican dudes
face that sold tacos and he's so long he
sold the mud sports night and he sold
bean and cheese that was the most
popular and he'd give you a sign of
salsa and chips and they kind of really
worked hardly like he would work the
kitchen and then how much eats taco
matters it had to be though each burrito
whatever like a Dawa I would mind like
500 went sauce on the side he just had a
great business and it was he came to
your dorm and on Mondays he knew of
Mondays he come over Sam left your five
[ __ ] when I was but that was that was
his thing his competition was a fat
Italian
till this day I cannot remember his name
he was in there for extortion and he was
definitely a federal doodad done about
12 years he wasn't a rat or anything
yeah I was in there with this Persian
guy that you still like he had like the
best Tupperware he must have been doing
15 years because he came from a prison
where he ordered in the catalog remember
that old tub or that was white and had
the blue lid and the blue lid it didn't
have the snap it was like it was just
like a [ __ ] circus tent
and he had this Tupperware li that he
just had old spices that we cleaned it
wouldn't come off and this [ __ ]
over and marinade all our food for us
man that was his hustle hey I'll I'll
cook for you guys give me a book and you
guys do the dishes it really [ __ ]
this crazy so this Italian guy put
together like irons you know yeah I know
exactly what you mean
alright so he look like Serrano mm-hmm
and some days he made spaghetti sauce
but his kiss claimed the fame was cheese
for nachos he probably melted it but the
sting so he took this finger he would
melt the cheese they put jalapenos in
there and salsa another type of cheese
and he would start at 7:00 in the
morning on Monday so again they would be
ready for Monday Night Football ah smart
and then he would take the sauce in the
one and then the other one he was boiled
water all day long just ball Warner
throwing spaghetti in there for four
minutes
take it out give you a bowl of spaghetti
from when their football it's [ __ ]
crazy delicious to die it's a crazy Lee
imagine Lee when you're imprisoned Lee
they took away salt and sugar so I
[ __ ] steal that [ __ ] or they
get it in a package and they're
marinating [ __ ] you you your taste
buds have been in prison too your taste
buds have been in prison and you eat
this [ __ ] it's like [ __ ] heaven why do
they take away your saucer
and sugar Arnold Schwarzenegger was a
mad that is that that him it's okay look
at when you when you're in prison you
belong to California now so if you're
getting diabetes and cancer they have to
treat you you're their prior you're
their property that's Sarah okay I do we
used to make grilled cheese you know
those old heaters the ones that are like
metal and they have like a little gap in
between right we used to put a paper bag
with a thread cheese and leave it in
there for 15 minutes if the bag was
sweaty you had yourself a sandwich the
thing that left the bag is sweaty the
thing ready yeah that's good the bag is
sweaty the sandwich is ready
I'll show you show it wasn't just any
sandwich oh you know I got to describe
the people like when you became friends
with somebody
oh man that was the weirdest [ __ ]
Woodleigh of me you hooked up okay right
we became friends and then we work
together and next thing you know we got
a house together maybe we made three
extra bucks a week cuz we did something
but then one night yelling hey man it's
a Jewish holiday time come on over I
think I don't know anybody and they come
over there and you got two cans of
sardines oh right so two mustard with
two packages of saltine crackers that
you got from the store sounds delicious
that's two cans of coke on you will be
become [ __ ] body's blood heroes now
you're saying it's their sick watch TV
here with me yeah and now we watch like
[ __ ] the sopranos and 6 feet under I
have to wait two cans of sardines forget
about it now the following Sunday I show
up with toasty nose little pizza bites
you get the sardines I get potato chips
and [ __ ] starving yeah so dude it's a
family money around how do you you got
for me I had two ways my girlfriend
would bring in stuff or we had a
20-minute furlough to the store every
day seven days a week but how do you get
the money for that it goes in your books
they sell it to their prison and then
ten record or you work yeah yeah for me
it was different I used to work in the
kitchen and then also my my friend's
family would send me money or I would
send them package orders
oh it's there's a package you can order
in there and you check all the stuff
that you want and you send it to them oh
man I fats
I had some [ __ ] great meals and I we
made tamales for Christmas
burritos [ __ ] atomic dogs atomic dog
is the [ __ ] well they really really
[ __ ] him dude do a lot of good things
yeah atomic dog is a hot dog with not in
hot dog bread but we curled the bread
hot dog mayonnaise mustard Cheetos
Fritos string beans [ __ ] corn
anything you could find let's create
diabetes Evan I better usually lepidus
City until you believe that it was
[ __ ] Club Med and I went skiing every
day but I will tell you one thing it
really wasn't as bad as I thought it
would be I agree with this how my tea at
the perfect time in my life what I
needed to get slowed down a little
straight up Joey it really gave me a
chance to when you're in the cell one
when somebody when you finally come to
terms of there's nothing you could do
because for the first three days after
the judge sentences you you obviously
start right rerunning episodes the Lord
all of it yet and you start coming up
with your presidencies [ __ ] but when you
finally come to the conclusion that
you're sitting here and you have
diagnostic yeah then you're gonna go
somewhere once you come
it's not that it hurts but it hurts so
much it becomes loving and it takes a
few people come back with that from that
being dumped and then not only feeling
love on the way in but then seeing what
you've never seen before in your life
straight straight up brutality survivors
I'm not gonna tell you that this happens
when you're present other thoughts head
this is our best experience well I'm
telling you is is that you might see
shooter to the shotgun shower huh
[ __ ] yeah the worst thing you ever saw
was I remember dog my first day in there
Lee well I'll never forget it man like
it says no no warning shots on the wall
all right and what does that mean no
warning shots is when there's a fighter
or riot they're not going to shoot that
they did shoot you a blocks or rubber
pellets alright so then I'm gonna know
they're gonna shoot right at you and
it's pretty [ __ ] crazy dog it goes
down like I remember flipping the [ __ ]
out I watching my first fight
fools falling now it's pretty crazy dog
so you own your first day are you scared
to be there well it's only your first
day in prison I was only scared because
like I heard like your older homies tell
you how to act call me Ted oh so tell me
so your friends we can look we know
where you go in your eye exact look dog
check it out this is who you talk to
right this is home this is not how you
act you don't [ __ ] roll it up you
don't do none of that [ __ ] and then you
get there and then they get you off the
bus and then I get [ __ ] butt-naked
and you get butt-naked and you walk
through these offices where people
aren't
suits there's women there's guys that
there's cop seals and then that's when
you flip the [ __ ] out that's when you
realize it's set in he's in the bathroom
yeah and I think I think I think he went
in the bathroom to try to do a bump off
the toilet no I know okay so it's just
an LS in the-- I'm sorry
the last sense I said was once you're
butt naked and you're walking through
like cops male and female cops say you
realize you're just a number now and
like you're in someone else's world yeah
dawg it's different it was all cool
because I got sentenced on Monday mm-hmm
and by Tuesday morning they sent me the
son of County and Summit County Jail was
like [ __ ] a playground it's a ski
resort so I started the first night I
know you can wear your own clothes your
own cell after your first you get your
first commissary they got TVs and radios
and raises of Mary how eating it was I
hand if you tip the guard ten bucks at
night at about 11:00 when the shift
commander left he'd go to a MP and buy
your groceries that nights of your put
pretzels potato for the first week I was
there was cool they came to me they told
me the truth they said listen by the way
you're not gonna be you're gonna be here
towards the holidays it's September and
I accepted it I said you know what
that's gonna be done even it was still
August I said you know what [ __ ] it I'm
gonna be there and yeah it is bad it's
two hours away from my girlfriend I got
money on my books like at Sunday MP I
had money in the locker room so I can
pay the grocery thing on Friday nights
he would let some one of us watch TV
outside till 1:00 and then you can watch
TV - what every time you wanted to your
room there's only three channels Lee but
it's better than [ __ ] being anything
and I came friendly to do from New York
and it was great but there was two dudes
in there
I will kind of [ __ ] particularly joy
oh yeah they've been there they're
checking you out two white dudes one
white dude would talk to me and the
other guy was yes man okay no big deal
boom Diaz wake up you're going to Canyon
City diagnostic that means the time come
you going to a big dance in the chain
I'm there for five days six days and
it's been tremendous but don't that lie
they told me I played a good attorney my
attorney told me was gonna get me
through the system quickly so I go up in
front of the judge and get my sense
reconsider yeah
so I said okay they got me through the
[ __ ] thing diagnostic boom first
night school second night school you
know you hear yelling all night
this ain't the life you had before
you're sleeping in a tent bed and it's
80 [ __ ] degrees Lee and you ain't
getting comfortable now you smile
everybody's [ __ ] farts you know so
now we're sitting there [ __ ] that like
the third day wouldn't the [ __ ] thing
I'll never forget this bro you ready and
it's four guys to a table okay you know
the section I was in had this black dude
that was beep papa but he was funny as
[ __ ] now at this time it was 1987 and I
can't tell you a majority but I can tell
you there was a good bunch of Crips and
bloods there because they were bringing
cocaine into Colorado yesternight okay
it was no big deal they were getting
arrested every weekend they were black
so as they come over the border what are
you doing here I came to ski but you
like overlook the ski bags ten thousand
pieces of rock come out of it [ __ ] so
there was a bunch of Crips and bloods in
there okay I don't know nothing about
this [ __ ] you know me dog I know about
coke and not that much I don't know
about Crips and bloods I find that in
there if you're a slob [ __ ] you know
you
yeah or whatever they call them they
don't have those in Jersey right Chris
is like 'days no idea but back then when
you were there they didn't I knew
nothing but yeah I did maybe I just
never saw it I didn't run it no I didn't
run in camera those I can't different
that's where those Crips and bloods was
invented those crazy places but to start
off in that lake and don't even run over
there I'm just making a joke okay I
don't know what's going on but I do know
we're at lunch one day it was like [ __ ]
that you know all day long but you only
leave yourself a [ __ ] lunch good yeah
they give you an the showers every two
days every three days you took a shower
great program
you totally flush the toilet twice a day
yeah so you got [ __ ] now live with the
[ __ ] man uh-huh so my time and then save
the flush for at night
y'all don't [ __ ] like Deeley so I get
to the thing I sit down and it's me one
of the dudes I became I talking it with
a white dude maybe and there's a black
dude here and the black dude that was
sitting here was a dude I told I was a
job dude that was funny
baby DC whatever no why he's sitting
there he started jabbing jabbing which I
didn't understand by saying nothing
disrespectful they start saying
something about crap this is crap and I
could you know blah blah blah blah and
also you know and now there's there's 60
people in a dining room everybody hears
this [ __ ] it's totaled my 10th day in
and I'm finally in the valley of
darkness and this cool this is a [ __ ]
leg you know bah bah bah
as a matter of fact I heard that punk
ass right there right there right there
look up at me [ __ ] I heard that
you follow up a tree with a bag
ambulance and a leather jacket on his
shed and I was sitting there
and I just busted out I didn't know I
couldn't bust out or I could bust out I
didn't know what the rules were
he just made a joke and I was laughing I
don't know if he even said it that way
George really does that [ __ ]
fell out of a tree with a fox and I was
like huh
he goes what the [ __ ] you talking about
[ __ ] I've been here for [ __ ] Strand
gangster murder he goes no you wait you
had him for child molestation [ __ ] you
know you molested those kids you nasty
ha ha that's a wrap and bro listen from
the [ __ ] over there I saw a black
dude eat his last pork chop in that
piece of cornbread and he took that 10
yeah he started banging that black goose
had told blood started squirt and that
was my second day diagnostic I was like
okay I hope those push-ups work the guy
who hit the guy's head well they got a
catch I'm probably so yeah we're so
lucky no one's on those cameras there's
nothing there's no cameras oh those guys
only in federal prison you're it there's
no there's cameras on level-1 level-2
yards not in maximum security
ha they're not cameras in prison in
those days Lee it wasn't how it is now
the cameras black and white blurry you
know there can't be cameras do you know
how many [ __ ] guys just right there's
a thousand holes so people come to you
Lee you got a beef with these yet listen
after lunch
he walks Judy blocked but he goes around
the office there there's not a Cameron
miles hide in the bathroom and get him
when he goes through and pull him into
the bathroom the stabbing
don't never see you do Italy yeah they
don't have cameras either because the
cops will get in so much trouble from
what they're doing so very you stab me
we you cut me open
I go down George's waiting outside you
pass the knife on to George George keeps
walking I'm out
George passes the knife to another
friend of his gives it to another friend
of his for $10 that's a good night but
you have blood on it it works it's sharp
you know saying it's a good piece right
there gee mother that's more than a
piece that's a firearm and there you
have a strap now you can hide that
[ __ ]
bury it that's that's survival Lee let
me give some shoutouts real quick the
funny blood truth quick draw mcgraw
Chris Lister pork Antonia Frankie
trailer Bryan moody Dustin ran from
ELISA
coz Mina and my man Rae [ __ ]
tail like I told you Irvine is sold out
George Perez will be there with me yes
but I'll be at the Nova theater downtown
at the Microsoft December 3rd I'll be at
the observatory in San Diego the 4th and
the observatory Santa Ana I'm opening up
for my main man
wheeler Walker [ __ ] jr. I'm
telling you get tickets cuz they gotta
go quick they're cheap and this is it
this is comedy and country come together
r-rated take it or leave it [ __ ]
we're making a comeback but anyway back
to George Perez you said something very
interesting George or Jordan well you
know you since we were kids
Jesus Christ that was a kid I'm lucky
dog we go back to 2006 because Marilyn
was still yeah and we shot the show and
before that I knew you you would not
like the rest of the people you had
heart and you were loyal and I knew that
you're walking down the corner a death
once before and then so [ __ ] went down
would take the Showtime special you came
out and it's like you came out
he came out like you know like Joe gallo
like you you came out focused oh yeah
well they take away everything you have
like in there imprison all you have it's
time to think of what you want to do and
when you're out and like that's time to
[ __ ] do it it's just really weird I
mean you came out and within three weeks
you have a book on the rule and I look
field I own this [ __ ] kid you know I
thought you come out angry I was but I
wasn't angry and they have no idea I'm
looking they ought to be on to be back
doing comedy and you haven't really
missed the beat some of the same steps
were they disappeared yeah I checked out
on that and you do what you're doing
though it's crazy how you know I hate
saying this word but we're very
fortunate to watch the game how it
changed yeah when we got here there were
people who weren't touching oh and no
people a dead yes that careers are dead
they can't adapt to what's happening in
here we are still doing comedy which is
the main purpose of our mission here you
know I look at it so like that how
fortunate you are sometimes a guy like
Lee goes to college and he comes out he
wants to be some but he ends up doing
listen listen listen you know what the
ends up making a little money down the
wrong long one because they're
specialized in this field but it really
wasn't what he thought it was gonna be
he thought he was gonna be some
something completely different
and sometimes that's what life is all
about it's calling an audible and going
with something that you really [ __ ]
right up okay might a [ __ ] prison and
went right for it took me two three
years to get on stage that was such a
half of fact had already established
yourself before you were in there people
know who you are it was like when John
Gotti went to jail for stabbing the
Irishman people talked about you like
that like he's getting down since once
he's getting out in three months he's
getting nothing two months you know yeah
I was I was worried I was waiting man
cuz I was in prison and they were re
running all the specials on empty
yeah came out on they were showing
videos I was in Bakersfield and I guess
you guys were doing a show in
Bakersfield the Paso comedy slam I was
like [ __ ] I should be on that show you
know people always write me little notes
and they say creepy things I'm an
inspiration is she like that man
appreciate everything but I don't know
you would supply the [ __ ] out of me
George because this is a tough action
man this is a tough racket by the way we
are gonna ask you something yes sir
what's the place you hang you went last
week the open mic ah the fourth wall I
think it's called and it's unwell she
direct address of people I can get it
for you it's on purpose it's on Burbank
and it's a little has a complex it's 30
yards from police station guys now if
you hit the gas station you went too far
so you have to hit a gas station first
no you can't park in that oh I know you
can't we have to park around that area
but you see a 7-eleven you park your car
don't parking that said let me go told
you all she thought down the block walk
the dirty [ __ ] yard there's always
parking for police station yeah knows
that always park in front of police
station there's a dry cleaner back
there's another Republic there's a
Japanese restaurant no Donati back there
we ate back basil before now you took me
there I could take leaving everything
even there you come back it wasn't bad
what the salmon was kind of brown one
one six seven four and they're open wood
they're open every night eyes are the
open side is something I sample let me
uh let me check
we gotta start going there I'm because
if I get the lipstick special I work out
with starfish crap yeah I got some like
these I got about six eight weeks for a
half-hour now you got it I got it
if I don't get it then we gotta work a
different angle I'm gonna take a little
break and stand up maybe do a little
accent get back into the acting for a
few months get my [ __ ] pension going
I'm getting all
my getting mahalia if I can play a dad's
a couple of these roles go for it now
your are the perfect dad at the same
time you got a point there
what's going on Lee would you find up I
can't find that but when I was there
that think I'm pretty sure that it was
every night six and eight and then they
might have even more and it's really
cool because it's like I don't let his
colony you know what is hell
it's a comics and you gotta go up then
through six minutes for five hours
oh wow it's one of those deals joins and
takes you back to basics
when I was there was just whoever the
guy just counted how many ever coming
through then we got the time / comics
that's what he did there was there
another show afterward at eight yeah
that's crazy that's listen man
so I like that is the clock one year
that's the New York City comedy when I
swung I went back to New York for those
nine months and I thought I was going
back to Broadway
instead of glitter and hang out with
Liza Minnelli there was no Liza Minnelli
doug liman there's no life is Amelie I
would say open mic at leo steakhouse leo
stakeouts and yeah there was an open mic
but in the basement with no windows no
air conditioning I look there with sex
comics in the audience and you pay three
dollars to get in and three dollars for
water and the bartender was a dick and
the waitress was a bigger [ __ ] dick
and you got to go up there and pay and
do 7 minutes and die a slow death then
walk out of there and think about
yourself like really just what I wanna
[ __ ] do in my life his living [ __ ]
torture but I look at those things so I
saw what they built
yeah built humility that's what they
built and sometimes like I was telling
them George you know I'm not a young
dude bro I'm very happy that I'm
fortunate I'm healthy at the time I
could still do five shows a week and
give them my heart you know I'm saying
you don't know saying
I loved there being a robot I have it
now to do that type of work at my age
you do two weeks you're good for two or
three weeks you follow me huh you get
motivated you go back out there I gotta
tell you something George you don't seem
at The Comedy Store a lot I can't be out
till 2:00 in the [ __ ] morning one of
the more become peaceful takes you out
oh yeah its commitment to Comedy Store
it's a fun place yeah I'm there right
after this you know and it's funny how I
would have to I wish I get to death this
thing because it's gonna bring I want to
go back to the beginning I want to go
back to Rocky one ya wanna go you want
to go to the gym again you wanna go
right all over here I'm going back to
the gym again going back to the gym
again that's how you know anybody gonna
do a senator Comrie so every villain
millions yeah but to go back to the gym
to take three open mic this is say yo
call me at night let me know where
you're headed I'll be done in 10 minutes
you have to sell tickets yeah not the
sell tickets it's to go ah I'm gonna go
up there and talk about dumb [ __ ] and
every night I'm gonna go up and pull out
my iPhone those 10 minutes and every let
you get one gem yeah and you write it
down you get two gems three gems for
gems five gems ten gems and there you go
three jump three minutes on these gem
well you got get special 30 minutes
bubble that's what you're [ __ ] seeking
and that's the formula if not I'm gonna
go to the store and go into deep waters
and think my material sucks because I'm
not delivering with all I could tell
when I'm at the store and I can tell
when I'm on the road I'm two different
[ __ ] okay I'm a powerhouse on the
road
I ain't [ __ ] around I reserve myself
all day if I would have brought my kids
and got the turret yeah I said that room
all day just percolate like a [ __ ]
time by Hercules yeah love that [ __ ]
word that doesn't percolate coffee no
more that's the thing of the eighties
uncle Joey still percolates
[ __ ] as he forty gruffly what what what
we what is your problem I don't have any
problem sir everything good buddy yeah
everything's good have a good weekend
yeah head i gue again I
god bless you I'm really I'm enjoying
therapy I'm trying stuff that has scared
me before well I guess so it's like what
what scares you like each other surprise
eaten what chatted fries like it just
petrifies them I can't I don't like
orange things in my mouth no I'm saying
you know like Cheetos no that [ __ ] I
love Jews
you can't count the one time that had VD
and he put old God on his dick I'm gonna
trample there's lemons in it yeah the
time you dig yellow if you wash your
dick with it by mistake
sunny nurse slowly her son Ian he's like
the Lori's dick and hi Kenny carrots -
carrots one of my camp counselors listen
to his podcast now please go we're gonna
split what do a therapy podcast the same
enjoyment so people could start to Lou
you thinking about what Lee's talking
about so don't say that but no what do
you changes for 2018 what do you want to
make happen I'm gonna add so I'm gonna
cut out soda out of my life it's hard
yeah I've done it before I'm gonna
definitely cut out what do you drink
instead I drink water with like lemon or
like just water and juice like that's
one thing prison help me that's all I
got was water and water and milk yeah
you guys don't scare yourselves nah
my mother had a bar at the bar she had
coke and 700 yeah on rat that had racks
and had bottles and it was soda that was
somebody else range but it was the same
so it was called like cook pop and
[ __ ] lime up and I would drink that
[ __ ] constantly I'm scared of that whole
time here because between the ages of
four and [ __ ] them 40 that's all I drank
was [ __ ] so yeah but it was a
different in your time Joey no it was
not it was real coca-cola real [ __ ]
sugar in it they pour it on [ __ ] the
hood of a car but it was in bottles
who gives a [ __ ] if it's in [ __ ]
somebody's [ __ ] and you sip it out with
a straw I don't [ __ ] man
it's still coca-cola in your system yeah
and you think about all I'm I took the
scroll down I can't do it I can't I
can't believe I wean myself off it hurts
a little 10 years no I'd the Coke Zero
with a ton of ice cubes and I had the
new one with the s'ti brand at the
sabina have you ever gone from not
drinking soda for a while then to have a
can of soda it hurts your mouth it's
like it's hard what are these bars I was
addicted to soda I wasn't able to cover
the cost
that wasn't a meal that tasted right
[ __ ] water what I'm a Fresno War I
got a drink [ __ ] the water like I'm home
I'm gonna have a soda Highland suck my
dick give me [ __ ] two cans of coke
with plenty ice cubes I mean broke fried
rice I'm already going now yeah when I
went to Chinese food this time I drank
water
yeah I mean I prefer a juice like a tea
I like tea I said I started to drink now
I'm drinking is our tea is fantastic
yeah that [ __ ] you know what's
killing America bro I see it all the
time the energy drinks no sugar nope
well you're in the ballpark stress
that's one of the factors but [ __ ]
Starbucks
yeah Starbucks Starbucks is destroying
America I see these [ __ ] people who
are ginormous they're about to bust
through the same and they've got
basically the 800 sugar cavalry for
breakfast ah you know what that does to
ya appetite the rest of the day
see I didn't know this until I was like
35 and somebody sat me down and go come
here a second you know that so do you
have a breakfast every day with your
eggs you think it's cute let me show you
what it does to your body the rest of
the day as the next lock in it'll does
something that it makes your body craves
sugar the rest yes so now all day long
and you're craving sugar
sugar in it that you don't even know as
sugar in it
yeah like Twinkies no like a steak
sandwich with a certain sauce on okay
and that sauce everything with the
corner - worn syrup okay yeah a corner
whatever the [ __ ] you know I'm saying
like wine that really it's like when I
was 19 I worked for the carpenter and
this guy was cool with [ __ ] I don't know
what his [ __ ] name was guys he had a
problem he [ __ ] drove a car off a
cliff they hit himself
no he was like point 22 [ __ ] level
alcohol he lived he went but at that
time they didn't really know about duis
now they were no it was like it wasn't a
profit yeah there was an enough dollar
it was late to a three they didn't catch
her they didn't take a blood test but
they want him to take a drug and alcohol
class and one Saturday or Sunday I was
doing somebody knows listen I tell you
what if you take the ride with me I'll
Drive you there back for free just come
to the first class let me tell me you're
my brother so I have never forget this
and they said this is what happens to
you when you drink alcohol the first 30
minutes and they broke down what happens
to every part of your body and then then
they compared it to what happens when
you smoke marijuana was two different
worlds right there I was in the end all
alcohol frame and after I saw that video
I never really wanted to drink again
even though last night I was sitting in
the house my wife was sleeping the baby
was sleeping
it was nothing I wanted to watch I was
going over the lines for an audition and
we never frigerator to get some water
and guess what I seen little more
[ __ ] no great Tabaka
who I blame about Irish cream Bailey's I
shook it up I pull it up with two wife
Hughes and I left it out for about three
four five ten seven minutes so the ice
cubes started melting and I mixed it
around I drank it like a gentleman by
myself I get [ __ ] up [ __ ] yet these
Irish cream makes you feel like a Cosby
victim that's when you know you out all
levels of yeah
I can't drink for [ __ ] Jack
so what else you wanted to do in 2008 I
mean you have this movie working yeah I
mean I'm ready is locally yeah I I want
to work on my I want to put more content
out I'm gonna start shooting like little
sketches and [ __ ] amen I just want to be
relevant but I want to be in everybody's
mouth and I just I want to keep climbing
and I'm just keep learning and getting
better I'm I'm ready to start you know
I've been in the game for a long time do
I have an hour special no but when it
comes it's gonna come I'm not gonna
cheat my fans I can do it now but my
visions there but I don't know how to
put it to my vision yeah it's coming
it's a very hard thing especially you
want to put something out there go this
is going to be around forever see wall
it's something out I've never had any
really whatever so I don't know what's
out there
you know maybe they find pleasure and
some other things but no no I've seen
you it broke thank you brother
I remember the special you shot at Sal's
right before I went to prison oh yeah
ten ten of mm yeah that was some crazy
[ __ ] that is one of the worst pieces of
footage I've ever seen in all my life
it's right before I may I went down this
so unprepared you're nervous his [ __ ]
it wasn't that I was nervous choice it
was then you know what's that song
there's a time to fold door when cold
now when hold I'm lonely for them the
[ __ ] what is that song you know Kenny
Rogers the gambler I've seen so many
people in this town make mistakes but
you're not here to bust anybody's dreams
when somebody comes to me and said bro
you know I gotta win this I got an idea
let's shoot a special on my high school
oh my god I'm gonna shoot it for free
and baklava and then you go good luck to
you and you can't figure out why this
shows the special you can't figure out
and they come to England Lena this did
you know I love the guys that kunti and
say
special shoe for 3,000 and I got hooked
up wait till you see it wait the
innocent or there's going to be a by the
way somewhere that 3000 you [ __ ] up
glossed it
you [ __ ] up I made a seven thousand
dollar investment I ate a bag of dick
after everything it cost me like 10 I
ate a bag of dicks
I took the loss like a man but I've
learned a valuable lesson that's how you
teach a man molested go into the [ __ ]
pocket yeah for real you hit yourself in
the pocket and that's how you learn a
valuable lesson you shut your mouth and
your mind your business when come comedy
that is falling to shoot the special I
don't want to shoot it leave my Lions
here no I don't wanna shoot it
eventually gave me a number that worked
they didn't really work but for what I
had going on I might as well jump on it
but that whole business is a weird
business yeah I wish to god there were
suddenly with 60 grand I go you know
what is the 60 let's go shoot at this
place boom boom boom get the copyright
you know whether it's Netflix HBO
Beauvoir
we control the whole thing and that's it
you know we'll split the investment or
something like that I think it's copy
rather than that we sell CDs on one we
figure it out there's always a way to do
it because what my point is there's a
way I don't when to do it
timing is everything mm-hmm I've seen so
many comics for always hundreds of
thousands of dollars a thinking they
gonna put some not the biggest joke in
this industries web series I love these
guys that spend all this money on the
web series and only those of the [ __ ]
they are and now one of them moving
decides to get a [ __ ] web presses a
year before he puts out the series to
have a web series you have to have a web
presence and then the web series falls
into place but to just take people you
know you have a big platform from 9:00
to 5:00 and we weep with a tell about
this [ __ ] forever I'm his nurse [ __ ]
that I'm sorry George you're fine you
and the red shirt it's tremendous you
remind me of American make way for
[ __ ] Jimmy Smits the knock on the
door I'll stab his ass oh
you know what they do that coming up
tomorrow I'm at The Comedy Store Monday
at secret show me red band Brendan
Schaub Christina Hutchinson from the
guys we [ __ ] podcast yeah tomorrow
night Wednesday you with me and
Wednesday I'm with you nerve idly you D
egg yeah Thursday I'll be at the house
just cuz of you dog I'm getting Boston
Market this year are you really yeah I'm
not cooking one this year don't do it
I was just joking around there's gotta
be a cousin that you could pay Sally
just walk away and make a turkey for you
I really don't like that [ __ ] you don't
like the Spanish drinking I don't like
I'm over it like what do you war
honestly it's like you and me
I gotta be other fit if you'd like you
come on Lance here's the problem with
Thanksgiving with me
I eat turkey one time I hate that prison
stuffing some mashed potatoes you got a
piece of pumpkin pie with some whipped
cream on it hit the road and I'm good
too my wife sits there with the turkey
what do you want tomorrow turkey
sandwich listen I might want to see
turkey sandwich again unless I go to
County Jail surgery because that [ __ ]
with the [ __ ] little sperm on it
mm-hmm it's like a thin coating a sperm
at the hospital with the American cheese
and dough in the mayonnaise that comes
in a package with the apple juice
tremendous it makes you sleepy that's
right they give it to you and it won't
work for [ __ ] ever you're half a [ __ ]
turkeys in than that
they call it tryptophan but that [ __ ]
don't work on uncle Joel you know uh
Lisa are we feeling my brother I'm can
break what are we doing for Thanksgiving
will he disclose what we're doing talk
to me I'm not sure I was drunk enough
Vegas first that your brother must stay
here and I think we just gotta pause mom
for a minute and then I'm missing you
and then we've got me going to Vegas
Friday who knows I think you're making a
good mole I think you should partake
with your family on Thanksgiving Day and
go to bed nice and early about 8:00 and
we'll sue column Inc in the morning
before you leave get on the 101 and
9 right you have about 1/2 you can't
check until 3 you stop up your favorite
Stumbo we placed make sure you work out
good next week you do push-ups and
kettlebells I'm excited I have a troy
Conrad take you lent my pictures in
December please get into the commercial
business that's what I eat yeah he's
been telling me for years
I'm live in Los Angeles you a non-union
right all these commercials you see 65%
a non-union now that's why all these
people are getting their only pensions
that's why all these people are saying
you know what [ __ ] it I'll go up because
there's a way to shoot non-union
commercials when you sang but you have
to give up your benefits [ __ ] that you
have to give up some type of benefits
see you still got a pension but not ever
since you taken they call it something
I'm not sure don't quote me on it
so this is a mistake - is it a mistake
to go Union like everybody if I go my
first day and they're like listen you do
better did it for the next year you do
done using commercials when you make a
hundred grand is that possible
well leave your live in the city or
anything is possible you have more of a
chance of doing that than [ __ ] let's
pretend you go for a commercial and you
get Mattel like a [ __ ] dwarf and they
put like a Vinny warhead hat on yeah I'm
just saying it to you and also George is
the director of marketing for something
and he thinks you're perfect for the
mascot for some Travelocity channel you
would that little [ __ ] hat on and
they'd shoot you
you know whatever timescale and then you
shoot 22 commercials like that chick
from [ __ ] or whatever weight that
puts in your pocket I have no idea not a
lot mention the sag insurance not to
mention that you played during the
Superbowl whatever my union or non-union
Lee at this point in life who knows
because the hackers strike it [ __ ] it
all up
gotcha now let's pretend you get a union
job okay I need it for union job let's
pretend in the year million in job that
means your sag eligible and that means
before you shoot that collage you're
gonna get a call
hi my name is George Perez I would Chris
egg I see here you booked the commercial
from Panasonic there's only one floor
here that you're eligible for sagging
and the only way to shoot this sad
commercials repeat will become a sec not
tomorrow will be open 9:00 to 5:00 we
take Visa MasterCard we also take a
finance plan how are you planning on
paying FERS and you're like paying for
what and no way to join the Screen
Actors Guild now it's 30 to 50 to join
you like thirty two hours and fifty
cents no no no sir when we bring it down
to you sir it's $3,250 Wow it's probably
2,500 right now 2750 it was 1250 when I
got here I gotta wave because the
production company paid for it but they
don't do that no more
now these are over those days are over
so yeah what do you have to lose you
live here you go to a nice commercial
and you start getting calls in the
afternoons you got somewhere to go now
you can mingle you meet new people I
went to audition I went to to our dishes
to last week
now I haven't tell you something what
was it Burbank and the other one was in
Hollywood somewhere I didn't want to go
and didn't want to be at both places you
know what I felt a little rejuvenated
and that's why I asked my agents inside
every time I fell for you guys you
thankful your he talked about is [ __ ]
me going here and being on there how
about the other line floors in your
building and Jefferson said I blew you
but I have a [ __ ]
IMDB rating you're like 3,000 yeah what
are you doing my doing why am i doing
the road let's get back to the movies
let's get back to some TV and then once
we get in you're all going then we'll
talk about the road again but for right
now there's no reason to keep me out
there like a wet dog there's no reason I
got a family had a wife or hip and one
guest
we gotta worry about I'm right here with
you brother blood you're still doing
your thing Lisa Ads doing his thing
Mama's doing her thing should you need
to [ __ ] started that tonight you know
I don't blame you
you learned your lesson you play with
the devil you come back with a scar and
yet anyway it's Thanksgiving the
holidays are upon you and you're still
[ __ ] around and you're still single
you don't know why every time you go on
a date the chick leaves the next you
don't even spend the night you know why
cuz your balls and your [ __ ] think
like that that's why but now it's
Thanksgiving it's time to express
gratitude and when we collect I want you
truly grateful for this year make sure
when your family shits in your house
they leave with a clean [ __ ] you get
a Toshiba day
you like joy what's a bidet - portable
bidet that snaps on to any toilet okay
and next thing you know before you shoot
you you get up and waste two trees I'm
wiping your ass and making it sore
tell them we how this will go down oh my
god it's it's gonna change your life you
sit down and with with the twist oh you
only need two fingers to twist it and
twist and and you're clean I have a cold
water only when I haven't tried the hot
water hot water is the way to go I love
I like cold water wakes me up I like it
all cold water in my ass why I want hot
water nice steamy to kill all the
bacteria you know the bad [ __ ] fungi
I go to the shower after to do that
that's a double clean that's a
tremendous clean means you care about
your people
I do you care about the people around
you but listen talk is cheap why let
your parents and cold parents and
Grandma walk around that house with that
rotten ass and then sit on your couch
watching the football games arrestor
they [ __ ] them make sure when they go to
your bathroom they got a cushy in their
affordable day that snaps on to both
bathrooms and don't let them use your
bathroom send it to the bathroom around
the corner tell them that the pipe is
broken in your bathroom nobody sits in
your bathroom your nasty [ __ ]
they come over with the nasty ass balls
and [ __ ]
[ __ ] that send them to the bathroom next
to the garage I don't give a [ __ ] of a
dull heavy hello
Toshi calm right now hello [ __ ] calm
use the cold word church for 10 percent
off your order the best bidet in the
business it's $69 with a free wrist
60-day trial
listen to me it's time you clean you
[ __ ] hello [ __ ] dot-com we'll do
that for you use the code word Church
for 10% off your order number to let me
tell you something it's the holidays
you're gonna bend you're gonna eat it's
acceptable but now you're gonna start
the year off and you want to eat healthy
this is wrong so Joey comes in you ready
blue apron Joey what's blue apron it's
the number one fresh ingredient and
recipe delivery service in the country
blue aprons mission is to make everybody
incredible home-cooked meal accessible
to everyone they achieved this by
supporting a more sustainable food
system setting higher standards for
ingredients and building a community of
home chefs blue apron offers three plans
the two-person plan the meals that serve
two people choose from ain't no recipes
per week the family meal plan meals that
serve four people and choose from four
new recipes per week with a choice to
receive either two three or four recipes
any week and the white plant Oh six
bottles of wine from renewed winemakers
delivered monthly let me tell you
something you have no idea I was raised
the way put it what's the last thing you
had on blue apron week I had the crispy
chicken tenders with hot honey potato
salad and many a cucumber ah I love
potato salad so I was really excited to
get to learn how to make it and the
chicken tenders are are you breathing a
little bit but then you pan you can cook
them in the pan it's great
let me tell you the recipes for the
month but it's squash pasta with kale
and brown butter walnuts Oh roasted
chicken and fall vegetables
and Mary and ginger kompot can you make
that no barramundi
with mixed mushrooms with jasmine rice
and napa cabbage you've never dreamed of
making that look at this one
seared steaks with garlic butter with
oven fries and romaine salad are you
kidding me
or watch listen to me - meaning yourself
a favor blue apron is gonna take care of
the Church of what's happening now the
family to their first dinner they're
gonna buy it that's it a $30 value visit
blue apron comps last Joey so check this
week's menu again it starts off with the
seared space and garlic butter with oven
fries and romaine lettuce II and you
imagine making that after dinner you're
inviting a little girly pull over you
put that on the dish forget about it the
rest of the - nothing but you know the
goods anyway boy print is treating my
listeners the first to their first
dinner during our value this visit blue
apron calm flash Joey that's blue aprons
doc calm slash Joey you know why cuz
blue apron is a better way to cook
remember families that cook together
stayed together also the holidays are
coming will fly a Black Friday Jewish
people up and down Friday I don't know
what to tell you is little for a TV set
I'm gonna get up with the best gear in
the business Fujiki period go to fuji
comm fuji sports.com right now Preston
Church I'm gonna give you a 10% off any
gave me I got the super raid oh I got
the cycle s e i KO this ACO
and I got the elemental especially a
blue one that they sent me I haven't got
it down that's where I go on Tuesdays
with the elemental I show up with the
blue elemental and that's how we do it
as usual a real pleasure to have my
brother George Perez on the show and
watch them make growth to see somebody
else who was locked up and did something
instead of becoming a [ __ ] statistic
like the rest of us we we became a
different statistic so it'll be uh what
are we in 2017 yeah I got out in 2009
November 21st
that's why eight years yeah well this is
how it is you find it you find something
that overpowers your ability to want to
do something listen it took the company
a long time to over powder cocaine yeah
I'm not gonna sit here [ __ ] you okay
then time to go hand in hand after you
have a great set you get off your friend
gives you a bump you get free drink
tickets but who needs a drink ticket you
already gave the Filipino guy 20 and you
walked it you're drinking double make
his mark the whiskey's that would kill a
meal you got a little burr on standby
you got the Armenian wing by the House
of Blues under a tree waiting for this
signal it's going down so it's tough but
they listen life goes on
brotherly what's up I was like George
when you first went to prison do you
think you're gonna be able to make it
back when you got out like did you think
you're gonna be able to make it back to
comedy yeah when I first got there that
wasn't on my mind the only thing on my
mind was to survive and like stay it
you're not thinking comedy when you're
in there I didn't think a comedy until a
guard recognized me I didn't want no one
to know what was a comic and cuz I
wanted less contact with people you
don't want you don't want everyone same
[ __ ] high to you and all that [ __ ]
right okay yeah but when I got out joy
was the first one I ever performed with
so but I'm just talking about evens
career-wise Oh career-wise like yeah we
were like oh [ __ ] my life's over I I did
think that I was just like you know but
I didn't know I was such a rookie comic
still that I just I don't know dog Lee I
come from there's nothing stopping me
love 40 years old like I wasn't thinking
that I was just say you know what
I gotta get in this prison not not get
stabbed no born a catch extra [ __ ] I
need to do my time when I get out I
gotta [ __ ] get my grind back on your
career would never stop either
god forbid something happens
the bangla prison yeah with the six
months of prison guard would come up to
me no listen Thursday nights want you to
accomplish oh yeah ice cream in this and
they'll pay you this for education
funding something and next you know
there's your career and you're helping
other people get paid career that's what
I'm thinking about going back to one of
those places again to doing comedy
because I want to be around young comics
they inspire you
yeah I true that watch what the [ __ ]
they're doing you're like that's what
these [ __ ] are doing mix it
with what I'm doing
are you kidding me you ever see like a
baseball team that they young and then
for some reason they got an old guy yeah
the Cubbies and that waldo guy has the
year of his [ __ ] life he hits 22 home
runs and 16 RBIs and he's up for the
Golden Glove Award why because those
young guys taught him new [ __ ] tricks
your problems Andy
pay attention Lee had [ __ ]
George Perez what's the name of your
podcast George Perez stories I'm gonna
come on before the end of the angry man
war and I love you heavenly and I love
Lisa at have a great daily we were back
Tuesday stay black
see you [ __ ] in Sactown or with
my brother we love Walker on the 3rd 4th
and 5th
have a good night have a good day have a
good week happy no with what we'll see
before Thanksgiving
ciao late